OK, let's unpack this.
Imagine a place where, like,
every single decision feels like
a trap, or even a fleeting
moment of peace.
Is this luxury you can barely
afford?
A world where you, the mortal,
are constantly forced to choose
between, well, the unthinkable
and the unbearable?
That's the chilling reality
we're diving into today.
And what's truly compelling
here, I think, is the sheer
suffocating weight of these
choices.
You know our source material for
this deep dive.
We've got these some ticulously
detailed session notes, player
accounts from a recent
adventure.
They just vividly illustrate
this unending struggle.
Yeah.
It's not merely about the
mechanics of survival, the dice
rolls and stuff.
It's a profound exploration of
the moral, the emotional cost of
every single step our
protagonists take in this land
defined by despair.
And that's exactly our mission.
With the Deep Dive, we take your
sources, peel back the layers
you know, and extract the most
vital Nuggets of knowledge.
Get right to the good stuff.
Exactly the surprising facts,
those crucial insights that make
you truly well informed.
Today, we're distilling the
harrowing journey of a specific
group of adventurers through the
cursed land of Barovia.
We'll trace their encounters,
reveal their shocking
discoveries, and ultimately
unravel the chilling cliffhanger
that left them branded as
heretics.
Yeah, that was something.
Prepare for twists, turns,
profound moral dilemmas, and,
frankly, truly unsettling.
Moments definitely unsettling.
So to truly understand their
plight, we first have to grasp
the nature of Borovia itself.
This isn't just like a backdrop.
No, it's a living, breathing
antagonist.
Our sources describe it as a
valley perpetually wreathed in
mists, where sunlight barely
touches the earth.
You can almost feel that, can't
you?
You really can.
The pervasive damp, the chill
that just seeps into your bones,
reading the descriptions and
looming over it all is Count
Strad von Zarevich.
The big guy himself.
The vampire Lord who overseas
his domain with the patience of
eternity, watching everything.
It's a place where even the air
feels heavy, kind of pressed
down by an ancient, malevolent
will.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, Barovia isn't
just a setting, it's a unique
kind of prison.
It really is.
How so?
Well, the walls aren't physical,
right?
They're psychological,
spiritual.
Even.
The landscape itself reflects
the curse.
It's this constant mirroring of
the despair that permeates every
facet of life there that.
Makes sense?
The accounts vividly paint this
picture.
The people live in fear,
superstition, and hunger.
Hope is as rare as warmth.
And that's not just, you know, a
metaphor.
It's a tangible, crushing force
that relentlessly grinds down
spirits.
Every interaction, every
decision for those trapped
within its borders is profoundly
shaped by this oppressive,
suffocating environment.
It's an active, insidious
antagonist, constantly working
against any glimmer of light or
freedom.
So you get a palpable sense of
the pervasive gloom, right?
It's not just dark, it's
fundamentally broken.
It feels steeped in
hopelessness.
And into this bleak, despairing
landscape, a group of outsiders,
4 adventurers, have been
unwillingly drawn.
They're caught in this
nightmare, tasked with
navigating its many horrors.
Tell us a bit about who these
individuals are, because their
individual strengths, and maybe
their flaws too, are critical to
their survival or lack thereof.
OK, yeah, our sources introduce
us to 4 pretty distinct
personalities who find
themselves ensnared in Borovia.
First up, we have Soren
Ironwood.
He's an awesome art paladin.
OK, Divine Warrior type.
Exactly.
A warrior of the divine.
His bloodlines trace back to
celestial beings, and he draws
immense power from his divine
oaths and radiant light.
But, and this is important, the
player accounts also highlight a
significant burden he carries.
Yeah, the arrogance of someone
who knows they are chosen, which
you can imagine can be both a
powerful driving force and,
well, a dangerous blind spot in
a place like Barovia.
Definitely see that.
Who else?
Then there's Radley Folthorn, a
human fighter.
He's an intriguing blend, the
notes say.
Masterful sword play with arcane
tricks, so he's incredibly
versatile.
Bit of a gish.
Sort of, yeah.
He's described as bold,
sardonic, and always the first
to leap into danger.
His quick wit and eagerness to
act make him a formidable
frontline presence, but also
maybe potentially impulsive.
Next to him is Tracidor 1/2 elf
cleric of the Life Domain.
He is the party's healer and
voice of faith, wielding divine
magic not just to mend wounds
but also to smite the undead.
Which is got to be crucial.
No Absolutely essential in this
land.
He represents that direct
connection to higher powers, the
conduit for healing and Holy
Wrath.
And the fourth?
Finally we have Dermont Cobain
1/2 Elf Swashbuckler Rogue known
for being quick with blade and
Wit Classic rogue archetype but
with that swashbuckler flair.
Nimble.
Clever, right?
But while his cunning and
agility are usually invaluable,
the session notes confirmed
Dermont was actually absent
during the events we're focusing
on in this deep dive.
Oh wow, so they were down a
person?
Yeah, meaning the party was
navigating the specific horrors
with a crucial piece of their
puzzle missing.
It just made their situation
even more precarious.
These aren't your typical
squeaky clean fantasy heroes,
are they?
Each one brings a distinct
flavor, and like you pointed
out, even their strengths seem
to carry a shadow potential
liability like Soren's
arrogance.
Exactly.
And it's not their first rodeo
in Barovia either, is it?
Our sources make it clear
they've already survived some
pretty horrific stuff,
collective horrors that would
break lesser individuals.
Oh yeah, the notes mention
undead trees, the terrifying
werewolves of the Ballenoc
Mountains, relentless vampire
spawn dealing with volatile
mobs, and even encounters with
angels who may not be sane.
Angels who may not be sane.
We'll probably come back to
that.
One, we definitely will.
It's just they've already seen
how the corruption there
permeates even supposedly good
entities, right?
So this raises a critical
question, doesn't it?
In a land like Barovia, where
this existential evil is so
pervasive and actively seeks to
corrupt, how do these individual
strengths truly hold up the
dynamic of this party?
You've got Cern's divine power,
Radley's Marshall prowess and
arcane tricks, Traxidor's
healing, and it's fascinating.
These unique abilities are
undoubtedly their greatest
assets, but as the sources show,
they can also be twisted into
potential liabilities in a world
that fundamentally corrupts
everything it touches.
Yeah, their past encounters,
vividly detailed in the notes,
show they've already faced
entities that challenge not just
their physical survival, but
their very sanity, pushing them
to their breaking points.
It's this constant, brutal test
of their resolve.
And this deep dive will reveal
just how much further they get
pushed to the edge.
Precisely.
And Speaking of being pushed,
this particular deep dive picks
up right after a really
harrowing encounter with
Shadows.
Nasty things.
Right, these terrifying undead
creatures that don't just kill
you, but drain strength from
your very soul, leaving you this
withered husk.
So the adventurers are
desperately seeking refuge in a
place that should offer respite,
the Abbey of Saint Markovia.
Should be in the operative word.
Definitely.
They collapse into a dormitory,
just utterly exhausted.
And what's immediately striking
is the profound irony of finding
sanctuary in Borovia, the Abbey,
you know, once this beacon of
healing and holiness, it's
become a grotesque den of
suffering.
How so?
What's going on there?
The sources explicitly detail
its current inhabitants, mongrel
folk.
These are people warped into
half human half animal forms by
generations of cursed healing.
Cursed.
That sounds awful.
It's a chilling testament to the
Abbott's twisted ministrations
and their howls, the notes say,
echo beneath the floorboards
like 100 nightmares, making
sleep incredibly difficult, if
not impossible.
Wow, so this isn't a haven?
Not even close.
It's a place where even just
resting is an act of struggle
against the pervasive despair
and this horrifying guttural
cacophony.
It really demonstrates that the
corruption of Borovia isn't just
some external force.
It has seeped into the very
foundations of supposed refuge,
transforming it into another
form of prison.
You think you're safe finally
after a tough, soul draining
fight, but the very walls of
your supposed sanctuary are
literally screaming at you.
It's like the land itself
refuses to let them find a
moment's peace.
Exactly.
And it gets worse, doesn't it?
Even that broken attempt at
sleep amidst the howls is
violently interrupted.
Absolutely.
The sources make it painfully
clear that in Borovia, even
sleep isn't safe.
The two shadows they had
previously driven off, those
terrifying, soul draining
entities, they did.
They seep back into the room
like liquid darkness less than
an hour into their exhausted
attempt at rest.
They specifically target Radley
and Tracidor, leeching away
vitality and leaving them
critically weakened.
The accounts vividly describe
the chaotic scene.
Radley scrambles for his sword
without armor, just a desperate,
vulnerable act.
Tracidor's prayers sputter as
exhaustion breaks his connection
to divine power.
That's terrifying for a cleric.
It really is his connection to
his source of strength.
Falters, spells fail.
The room just erupts into chaos
until Soren, roused by the
sudden attack, manages to join
the fray.
Do they manage to fight them?
Off again.
They eventually destroy the
shadows, yes, but it comes at a
significant cost.
The notes highlight they are
critically weakened, their
strength, both physical and
spiritual, profoundly
diminished.
This forces them to take shifts,
standing watch through the
remainder of the night.
Their brief respite is
completely stolen, their
vulnerability just laid bare.
That really drives home the
attrition doesn't.
It does.
The key take away here is
Barovia's relentless war of
attrition.
Victory offers no true respite,
only deeper exhaustion.
It forces these heroes to
confront their own rapidly
diminishing resolve resources at
every turn.
That's a powerful insight.
Their powers aren't limitless.
Exhaustion has immediate, real
consequences.
It underscores the pervasive,
relentless nature of Borovius
threats.
Even after a momentary victory,
the heroes are constantly under
attack, emphasizing that theme
of gradual attrition.
It brings into stark relief the
fragility of their power and
spirit.
This begs the question, how much
more can they endure before
their resolve or their very life
force breaks completely?
They're always on the precipice,
always just one more encounter
away from being entirely
overwhelmed.
And that profound fragility
leads them to press on.
Despite their depleted state in
The Pale Dawn.
Soren, ever driven by his
conviction, insists on exploring
the Abbey further.
Even though they're weakened.
Yeah, even as Tracidor, acutely
aware of their weakened
condition and frankly, the
disquieting presence of the
mongrel folk, warns against it,
their first stop is an old
Infirmary.
And the details our sources
provide are genuinely gruesome.
They paint a vivid picture of
the Abbey's horrific past.
I bet what do they find?
Well, the player counts describe
finding a surgery still smeared
with dried blood.
That immediately tells you the
kind of twisted healing that
must have happened there.
Then an even more haunting
discovery.
A nursery filled with rotted
cribs.
You can almost feel the phantom
chill of discarded hopes and
lost lives in that room.
And in a fleeting, unsettling
moment, Radley catches sight of
a spectral nun in a reflection,
A ghostly figure hinting at the
Abbey's past tragedies.
But she vanishes when he turns,
leaving her secrets
tantalizingly intact.
Creepy.
Just another layer of mystery.
It's a lingering, unexplained
mystery that adds to the
pervasive sense of sorrow and
unanswered questions.
But there's another detail here,
a seemingly small one, but one
that our sources explicitly call
out is crucial.
OK, as they explore a morgue,
which is described as bear
except for a Raven perched
outside the window, the bird
causes them excitedly before
flying down to the ground below.
A Raven?
Aren't those usually bad omens?
Usually, maybe, but the notes
specifically highlight that this
Raven is an omen of hope and
Borovia, a rare beacon.
Yet the adventurers ignore this
bird just consumed by their
immediate concern.
Nift Opportunity.
It feels like it.
It's a significant moment.
It's either a missed warning, a
lost opportunity for critical
guidance, or maybe just a
reflection of their increasing
weariness and tunnel vision in
the suppressive land.
The Abbey's full, horrific fall
from grace is vividly painted by
these details.
The gruesome Infirmary, the
spectral nun hinting at unseen
tragedies, and this ignored
symbol of hope.
It all contributes to a powerful
sense of decay, desecration and
poignant missed opportunities.
Here's where it gets really
interesting and frankly, quite
tragic, isn't it?
The details of this exploration
are chilling.
The spectral nun that forgotten
Raven.
What do those moments,
particularly the dismissed omen
of hope, mean for the
adventurer's journey
psychologically, maybe even
spiritually?
It really hints at a deeper
narrative layer, doesn't it?
A path not taken perhaps?
And their persistence, or maybe
it's just Soren's unwavering
will, leads them even deeper to
an even more terrifying
discovery beneath the Abbey.
Indeed, their decision to ignore
the Ravens potential warning and
descend further into the asylum
below, plunging Into Darkness
only illuminated by their
magical lights, leads them to
something far worse.
OK, bracing myself.
Our sources describe a massive
flesh golem stitched together
from human parts.
And this creature isn't just
another monster, it's explicitly
called an unfinished cousin to
the Abbott's creation, Vasilka.
Right, the Corpse Bride we'll
get.
To exactly and the stitching on
this Gollum is noted as being
cruder.
This immediately suggests a
spectrum of the abbot's
grotesque experiments.
Vasilka is the relatively
speaking, refined masterpiece,
and this Gollum is a more
primal, perhaps failed attempt.
It's a chilling insight into the
escalating scale of the Abbot's
depravity.
It's not just sitting there, is
it?
It's active.
Oh, very active.
Soren, ever the paladin,
attempts to speak with it.
Maybe seeking to understand or
even offer solace.
Noble, if maybe foolish.
Perhaps, but it answers only
with fists that crush and shock
with electrical bursts.
The heroes, depleted as they
are, fight briefly but are
quickly forced to retreat by its
rage and power.
OK, so it's powerful.
Immensely.
But what truly struck me reading
the player accounts was the
description of its terrifying
impact.
It stomps shake the very
foundations of the floor, and
its fury silences even the
mongrel folk.
Wow, it silences the howls.
Think about that.
A creature so profoundly
terrifying, so utterly
destructive, that it manages to
quiet the constant madding howls
of the mongrel folk.
It speaks volumes about its
power.
Yeah, that's that's a measure of
horror right there.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, this encounter
powerfully highlights the sheer
brute danger of the Abbot's
creations.
The Golems immense physical
force, combined with those raw,
uncontrolled electrical attacks
demonstrates A terrifying,
unstable mastery over desecrated
life.
They're.
Definitely unstable.
The fact that it's rage silences
even the mongrel folk underlines
its immense, terrifying power
and the depth of the horror
festering within the Abbey.
This raises an important
question about that blurry,
dangerous line between creation
and desecration, especially when
the being performing these acts
claims to be an Angel of light.
Right.
What was the Abbot even
thinking?
What was his ultimate intent
intention for this monstrous
creation?
Was it a guardian, a weapon, or
simply a horrifying byproduct of
his twisted, deranged vision of
salvation?
The unanswered question just
adds another layer of dread to
the Abbey secrets.
Shaken but seemingly undeterred,
they return upstairs, and this
is where they finally confront
the mastermind behind these
horrors, the one responsible for
the Abbey's twisted reality, the
Abbot himself.
And the scene they walk into is
just profoundly disturbing.
It's like a truly baroque
tableau of madness.
It truly is a scene out of a
nightmare, yet presented with
this bizarre, serene grace.
Back upstairs they find the
Abbot, who, remember, is an
Angel claiming to serve the
morning Lord in the midst of
teaching Vasilka to dance.
The Silka, the corpse bride.
The very same described as a
pale, mute woman assembled from
corpses, A grotesque patchwork
of human remains created with
the chilling and utterly
delusional intention to Mary
Straud and redeem his blackened
soul.
Redeems with a Corpse bride.
Yeah, and Cloven, the two headed
mongrel folk servant, provides
them a Cobb soundtrack to this
disturbing lesson, playing the
Viola with an eerie competence.
So they're literally dancing.
They are, and our sources
describe her movements during
this dance as having a surreal
elegance, a fleeting moment
where the horrific reality of
her construction is almost
forgotten.
Almost.
But then, when Cloven stops
playing, her movements revert
immediately to jerky
awkwardness.
A puppet without strings, a
stark reminder of her true
unliving nature.
It's as if the music is the only
force capable of animating this
dead bride with any semblance of
grace or purpose.
And the Abbot?
What's his reaction to the
adventurers walking in on this?
He just smiles, utterly
untroubled by their presence,
calmly reminds them of their
tasks to bring him a wedding
dress for Vasilka.
He still wants the dress after
they fought his flesh column.
Apparently so, and the
adventurers agree to this
unsettling quest, though the
notes explicitly state that
unease gnaws at them.
I bet it does.
The profound insight here is how
deeply Borovia's corruption has
warped even divine grace.
The Abbot's Macabre project
isn't just twisted, it's this
chilling demonstration of a
supposedly angelic being falling
into utter madness believing A
corpse bride can redeem a
vampire Lord.
It's completely bonkers.
The juxtaposition of beautiful
music and graceful movement with
the gruesome reality of
Vasilka's creation is just
striking.
It perfectly encapsulates the
Abbey's utterly warped morality.
It forces us to question the
very nature of good and divinity
in Borovia.
Seriously, what are the broader
implications of the Abbot's plan
for Borovia?
Is this a genuine, albeit
deluded, attempt at salvation?
Or merely another layer of cruel
games?
Or perhaps something even more
profoundly twisted, A true
desecration masquerading as a
holy act.
It's hard to say.
And that unease gnawing at the
heroes is a powerful indicator
of their growing moral conflict.
It foreshadows how deeply this
task challenges their very core
beliefs and sets the stage for
future internal and external
struggles.
So, with this new, profoundly
unsettling mission hanging over
their heads, find a wedding
dress for a corpse bride being
offered to a vampire Lord by a
mad Angel.
The adventurers decide to leave
the Abbey.
You need to find answers,
supplies.
Maybe just get away from that
place.
Can't blame them.
But before they dive back into
the pervasive gloom of Borovia,
they find a momentary, precious
glimmer of something truly
hopeful, a stark contrast to the
horrors they just endured.
Yes, and it's such a vital
counterpoint, a brief but potent
moment of spiritual reprieve.
Descending from the Abbey, they
pause at a shimmering pool
beside a crumbling pavilion.
Sounds peaceful.
It is.
There's a statue of a man facing
east, and Tracidor, as the
cleric, immediately recognizes
it as the Morning Lord, an old
God of light, a nearly forgotten
deity in this cursed land.
As Tracidor kneels to pray, the
sources note a profound shift.
For a moment, the crushing
despair of Barovia.
Lifts.
Like actually lifts.
Yeah, it seems so.
A powerful, almost miraculous
sensation.
A villager named Maldean
appears, a gentle soul tending
the shrine, calling it the
Shrine of the White Sun.
She speaks softly, confessing it
is the only place she feels
peace.
And critically, the adventurers
for once, feel it too.
A shared moment of genuine
tranquility, however fleeting.
You see these small victories,
these precious pockets of light,
aren't they crucial?
It keeps them and us, the
listeners, from just sinking
into total despair.
Absolutely.
It's a poignant reminder that
not everything in Borovia is
corrupted, that there are still
vestiges of genuine good comfort
and even divine presence,
however rare and fragile they
may be.
It's a spark in the overwhelming
darkness.
And this raises an important
question about the true,
enduring power of such a place
in the land, so steeped in
darkness.
It's a fascinating detail that a
simple act of devotion and a
forgotten shrine can cut through
the despair, even temporarily.
The white sun offers a spiritual
reprieve, a reminder that
spiritual resilience and the
quiet, persistent power of faith
can still manifest, providing a
fundamental solace even in the
most cursed of lands.
It hints that there are forces
other than Straud's pervasive
evil at play, even if they are
few and far between, and that
hope the rare is not entirely
extinguished.
Rejuvenated, even if only
slightly, by that spiritual
reprieve, they move on to the
more practical matters of their
journey after securing
permission to re enter Kresk
from Lord Dmitry Kreskov.
Which is probably a whole story
in itself.
Probably they travel to the
Wizard of Wines now.
This is a vineyard they had
previously saved from a covenant
of druids and their blight
spreading tree, so they already
have a history and a connection
here.
It represents a different kind
of hope, doesn't it?
Not spiritual, but practical.
It absolutely does.
This location represents
tangible, ongoing defiance
against Barovia's corruption.
Our sources note that magic is
slowly returning to the soil
here, a clear sign of nature
healing, with buds sprouting on
vines long dead.
That's great to hear.
Davian Martikoff, the vineyard
owner, greets them warmly, and
the accounts make it clear that
the Martikoffs, who are secretly
were Ravens, part of an
organized resistance against
strawd, are actively repairing
the destruction caused by a
walking effigy named Winterson
Splinter.
The were Ravens secret allies.
Exactly.
This shows that there are not
just isolated acts of goodness,
but active, organized
resistances against Strad's
tyranny, quietly working to
reclaim the land.
The Martikoffs represent a quiet
but persistent defiance, a
community rebuilding and
literally healing the land
itself, which is a powerful,
inspiring counterpoint to the
decay seen elsewhere.
It's a moment of tangible
progress, a clear sign that
their actions have real positive
consequences, however small they
might seem in the grand scheme
of Borovia.
But that brief welcome at the
winery quickly turned sour when
they approach a rather grim,
indeed macabre task.
They need to deal with the
severed head of Henrik
Vandervoort, a man they had
previously killed for his
involvement in stealing holy
relics.
Right, the head.
OK, Yeah.
And apparently not everyone at
the winery is thrilled about.
It I can imagine.
Our sources reveal that Adrian
and Dag, the Martikoff sons,
scowl at them.
They're clearly disgusted by the
grizzly trophy that the
adventurers had left in their
wagon, Emrich's severed head.
Which they buried.
Yeah, the brothers had
unceremoniously buried it by the
roadside, so with directions to
the shallow grave, the party
digs it up, then tracks the
door.
Uses Speak with Dead, that
necromantic spell that forces a
corpse to briefly answer
questions.
Got to get that Intel somehow I
guess.
The description of this magical
interrogation is quite vivid in
the sources.
Dirt dribbling from its mouth
and it's slack musculature
begins to aurofacially twitch as
the eyes blink open.
That's in settling imagery.
Horrifying puppet like
animation.
It just highlights the grim
realities and morally ambiguous
methods required for information
gathering in Barovia.
No kidding.
So what does the head say?
Does it help?
Well, Henrik, compelled by the
spell, confesses that Strad's
minions ordered him to steal
Saints and Andrel's bones.
He claims he hid them in a
wardrobe's false bottom.
OK, a lead Santander's bones.
Those sound important.
They do.
But here's the kicker, the gut
punch of the revelation.
Oh no.
The heroes realized they already
found that compartment when they
searched his bedroom days ago,
and they only found money.
The bones were gone then.
So it's a dead end.
Completely.
The trail ends there, cold and
fruitless, and they just dump
Henrik's head unceremoniously in
the dirt, a symbol of their
frustrated efforts.
Wow.
What's profoundly striking there
is the immediate futility of
their macabre effort and the
moral ambiguity involved using
necromancy on a head.
The Martakoff Sons palpable
disgust.
All for nothing.
Exactly.
It highlights the deep,
frustrating nature of their
quest in Borovia.
Information is scarce.
Leads often go cold, leaving
them in this perpetual state of
uncertainty and setbacks.
So it raises the question,
right, What is the true
significance of San Andrews
bones?
Why would Strawd want them
stolen so desperately?
And the fact that they vanished
from a supposedly secure hiding
place implies A deeper, ongoing
plot, a mystery that continues
to elude the adventurers, adding
to their growing list of
setbacks and dangers.
With this lead utterly
exhausted, the party, frustrated
and still burdened by the
wedding dress quest, decides to
return to the Locky.
It's a larger town in Barovia.
Maybe they can find some answers
there, or at least a vendor for
the dress.
Makes sense as a next step.
But the city is profoundly
changed from how they left it,
and certainly not for the
better.
It's a chilling demonstration of
Strad's tightening grip.
The sources describe a dramatic
and unsettling transformation.
The party finds Valaki not as
they left it.
The kind of casual oppression
they once knew is replaced by
something far more sinister.
How so?
Lady Walker, a noble woman who
is now ruling in Strad's name,
has militarized the streets.
Patrols are everywhere, a
constant menacing presence, and
each patrol is accompanied by
dark robed wardens wearing
arcane amulets.
Wardens with amulets?
That sounds ominous.
It is.
This immediately signifies
Straud's increasing overt grip
on the region, using human
proxies to enforce his will and
instill pervasive fear.
And Tracidor notices a chilling,
deeply disturbing detail.
What is it?
1 Warden's amulet is glowing
with the infernal sigil of
Asmodeus, a prominent devil
Lord.
Whoa, devil worship out in the
open.
Apparently this overt display
reveals the new regimes dark
allegiances and the truly
terrifying corrupt nature of its
power.
Even the old Burgamasters Manor,
once a symbol of Awlaki's
previous, if flawed rule, is now
being repaired after a mob
attack and seized as the
official office of Reeve Ernst
Larnak.
Lady Watchers right hand
furnishings removed or burned.
A clear sign of a total regime.
This is a massive, alarming
shift, isn't it?
Volaki was already tense under
its previous ruler, Bergamaster
Volakovich, with his forced
festivals and desperate attempts
to cheer.
Yeah, all will be well.
Right, but now it's under an
iron fist and you can
practically smell the sulfur in
the air with those Asthmodeus
sigils.
It's not just a change in
leadership, it's a fundamental
shift in the city's very essence
from paranoid repression to
outright demonic allegiance.
It's a terrifying escalation.
And this new oppressive
atmosphere is immediately felt
at the city gate.
Absolutely.
At the city gate, the guards
immediately refuse them entry.
Their demeanor is cold,
unyielding.
Soren attempts to bluff his way
in, claiming they hunt
fugitives, Viktor Volakovich and
Isaac Strozny trying to, you
know, align themselves with a
new authority.
Does it work?
Not a chance.
The guard mocks him, his voice
laced with a disdain, saying
Vlaki has been scourged
thoroughly already, implying any
fugitives would have been caught
or eradicated.
Ouch.
Then a warden, identified by
that ominously glowing as a
Modaeus amulet, approaches and
commands them to leave.
His presence just exudes this
quiet, infernal authority.
Soren, ever the pragmatist
despite his divine nature,
resorts to bribery.
Does that work?
It does.
The warden greedily takes his
coins.
The bribe comes with a chilling
warning.
What's the warning?
They'll need special permission
to exit if they enter.
So Valaki's become a trap.
That's the profound insight
here.
This exchange vividly
demonstrates the new regime's
tight control and immediate
suspicion of outsiders.
The bribe warden reveals the
systemic corruption, sure, but
also the dangerous trap Valaki
has become.
Easy enough to enter with a
bribe, but seemingly designed to
be exceedingly difficult to
leave.
Which raises that important
question, is the warden's
warning just a bureaucratic
rule?
Or is it a subtle, sinister
threat, a way to ensure they
become ensnared within the
city's new devil lined order?
Maybe for some darker purpose?
It feels like the walls are
closing in.
Definitely feels that way.
Despite the warning and the
palpable shift in the city's
aura.
They gain entry, only to find
the interior equally unsettling.
Also, the atmosphere inside is
just tense.
The town is crawling with
soldiers and wardens, their eyes
constantly sweeping the streets.
They head directly to the
burgomaster's old Manor, which,
as we discussed, is now Reeve
Ernstlernak's office, the heart
of this new, darker bureaucracy.
And.
Getting in there is an easy I
assume.
Not at all.
Guards there immediately refuse
entry.
Just a wall of uniformed
contempt.
It's like hitting a brick wall
made a spite, isn't it?
Pretty much, But Soren's
commanding presence, that subtle
echo of his celestial nature
radiating and inherent
authority, it does manage to
sway the guards slightly enough
for them to call a secretary.
Progress maybe?
Well.
This is where the mundane
bureaucracy becomes its own kind
of monster.
A wiry but well attired man
emerges and upon seeing the
adventurers he immediately
sneers in disgust.
Oh, lovely.
He doesn't even bother to hide
his contempt.
He denies them an audience,
stating they'd need an
appointment a month from now.
A clear, deliberate stonewalling
tactic.
A month.
They don't have a month.
Exactly.
This encounter truly reveals the
new regime's utter disdain for
outsiders and it's suffocating
bureaucratic stonewalling, which
for adventurers used to facing
physical threats, is a
different, perhaps even more
infuriating kind of obstacle.
Yeah, fighting a monster is one
thing.
Fighting paperwork and disdain
is another.
Right.
The secretary's sneering
contempt highlights the complete
disregard for the adventurers
past deeds or perceived in this
new infernally influenced order.
They've faced literal monsters,
powerful vampire spawn, twisted
constructs, but now they're up
against pure, unadulterated
bureaucratic spite designed not
to kill them, but to isolate,
frustrate, and slowly grind down
their will.
It feels like a deliberate act
of psychological warfare, making
them feel utterly powerless.
That's a good way to put it.
So what does this all mean for
their journey?
They faced monsters and
horrifying creations, battled in
City is Undead, and now they're
just being stonewalled by a
sneering bureaucrat.
Their urgent mission?
Finding that dress, finding
answers, it's all stall.
Frustrated to their core by this
infuriating stonewalling, Soren
makes a bold, almost desperate
move, seeking to cut through the
bureaucratic nonsense with an
undeniable display of power.
What does he do?
He evokes his Celestial
Revelation ability, manifesting
his angelic wings glowing with
divine light and what our
sources describe as a display of
dominance.
Wow, OK, flashing the Angel
wings, that should get their
attention.
It certainly does, but this is
the climactic moment, a dramatic
and terrifying reversal of
Surin's intended intimidation.
The guards are, as expected,
taken aback by the paladin
sudden, radiant spectacle.
But the secretary's reaction?
It's entirely different and
utterly devastating.
What does he do?
He doesn't cower.
Instead, he screams in a high
pitch, his voice shrill with
venom.
They're heretics.
Arrest them.
Heretics for showing Angel
wings.
Apparently so.
The soldiers immediately move,
weapons drawn, and the sources
emphasize that the Warden's
amulets glimmer with those
infernal sigils of Asmodeus
responding directly to the
secretary's accusation, and the
session ends right there.
No surrounded.
Surrounded, caught in the trap
of their own making.
Just chilling.
Soren's very essence, his divine
power meant to inspire awe or
fear, is instead immediately
perceived as heresy by this new
devil aligned regime.
It's a profound and catastrophic
misjudgement of the new
political landscape of Valaki
and the deep, pervasive
corruption that has taken hold.
His inherent nature, a source of
hope elsewhere, is suddenly his
greatest liability.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, it underscores the
deep, fundamental conflict
raging within Borovia, the
hidden yet now overt war between
divine and infernal powers.
Soren's very essence, a beacon
of hope and a source of
righteous power in any other
realm, becomes a direct target
in this twisted reality.
That's terrifying.
The true insight here is the
dangerous nature of light in
darkness.
When divinity itself is branded
heresy, it forces us to confront
a terrifying truth about
Borovia.
That it's corruption is so
absolute, its moral compass so
inverted, that even the purest
acts can lead to condemnation.
Which leads to that question,
right?
What truly constitutes heresy in
a land where supposed Angel
creates corpse, brides and
devils walk the streets openly
dictating what is permissible?
Exactly.
It's a world turned utterly on
its head, leaving our heroes in
an impossible bind.
So where does that leave our
adventurers?
From a restless Abbey filled
with literal stitched together
horrors, to a fleeting, precious
moment of peace at the Shrine of
the White Sun, to being branded
as heretics in what was once
their tenuous refuge.
The Angel's power, Soren's
inherent divinity, has suddenly
turned into a noose, ensnaring
him and his companions in the
grip of a truly infernal
bureaucracy.
Indeed.
And the Abbot?
He still waits for a wedding
dress.
That MC Cobb task they've agreed
to, yet they are now cornered
and outlawed in the very city
where they might have hoped to
procure it.
In stride.
He waits, always pulling the
strings from the shadows,
watching as these impossible
choices force mortals to
confront the unthinkable and the
unbearable, twisting their very
essence against them.
In Borovia, we've seen how even
the most well-intentioned
actions, even the purest divine
manifestations, it can be
fundamentally reinterpreted,
weaponized, and ultimately
condemn you.
The very idea of an Angel being
labeled A heretic, It forces us
to consider what truly happens
when your inherent nature, your
very being, becomes a weapon
against you.
In a world where evil reigns
supreme, it's.
A heavy question.
What stands out to you about
this deep dive?
How do you navigate a world
where divinity is heresy and the
search for light only draws the
attention of deeper shadows?
It leaves us with a lot to think
about, doesn't it?